what is
5g and you know
what in your mind is something that that
that probably everybody thinks they know
but
they have wrong yeah what is 5g
i mean gosh you uh don't don't you see
it when you turn on your phone it says
5g
or you watch the tv commercials coming
through a town near you
right there's so much noise out there in
you know
hand waving and misrepresentation on on
5g and where it is but
but ultimately you know all that being
aside from a pure technology perspective
i look at 5g as being
probably one of the biggest uh
innovations since the
the invention of the internet and i say
that just simplistically because it's
where
you know wire line connectivity and
wireless tech connectivity start to
collide and we start to have ubiquity
between you know speeds and and access
and is one you know uh major aspect of
5g
but it's also you know uh will enable
a new generation of services as well i
mean really the the explosion
of the industrial internet and we talk a
lot today you know everyone everyone
wants to associate
wireless with being about voice and i
can game faster
or video and the reality is that's the
real value of 5g is enabling the
industrial internet it's really how do
we
to me it's it's the it's the foundation
for how it is we're going to move
forward in the reindustrialization of
this country it's you know if we can
roll out 5g
and we can do it you know in a
constructive way
we can create a next generation of
manufacturing jobs
and get back to where we used to be
which would be technical thought leaders
and telecommunications
and and we've lost that uh is the
reality and that's something americans
don't want to believe
but uh the data all speaks the truth and
but 5g
you know is is a to me is a major
underpinning
on our future economic viability as a
nation
i don't think i think we keep thinking
of it in terms of i'm going to watch
faster movies and
who gives a damn we gotta if we don't
get back to reindustralizing the nation
and using
you know using this uh the industrial
internet to be the underpinning of that
we got bigger problems
you